hi guys you might notice a slight change
in scenery today and then it's because
I'm at top universities in YouTube
corner should you go to university I
want to talk to you today about when I
asked myself that very question and I
didn't go to university for the longest
time I think a lot of you know that I am
in uni now eventually but the story
behind why I chose not to go to
university it's quite an interesting one
and it gives me a really good insight on
whether you should go to uni or whether
you shouldn't go to uni because in a way
I chose both so let's talk about that
[Music]
now quick disclaimer this University
video is all going through based around
my own opinions on University in this
Western culture that I live in obviously
I'm from England so I can't talk for
other cultures around the world so
please keep that in mind while you're
listening to my opinions and my advice I
want to walk you through a list of
questions that I found really helpful to
ask myself before I decided whether I
wanted to go to university or not as
well as sharing with you some of my own
experiences when I decided not to at
university and ultimately why I decided
to eventually go to university so I
really hope this can be helpful for you
and the first question is what do you
want to study it's a very important
question because every potential career
path has multiple different routes
towards that however some are a lot more
convenient a lot more successful if you
want to become things like a doctor or a
lawyer or a scientist these career roles
I imagine have a much higher success
rate of you becoming them if you have a
degree under your
however I am talking about that topic
very loosely because I have always been
more interested in the creative arts so
I understand from my own experiences
that when you're doing creative work you
don't necessarily need to be in
university for that I have actually
gotten way more experience and more
people noticing me within these
industries because of YouTube and things
like that of me just doing my creative
stuff in my own free time and showing it
online but that's just what I found from
pursuing what I wanted to do now
secondly I would ask would you be going
for yourself or is there an ulterior
reason why you would possibly be going
to university or even studying the
subject that you want to go and study
I remember being back in school and it
was a very normal thing to go to
university people just kind of expected
you to go straight from finishing school
and I was seen as a bit weird because
they didn't want to fill out my you cast
form for universities because I simply
wasn't sure exactly what career I wanted
to do yet so I knew that if I was going
to go to uni it was probably just
because I was being told by my lecturers
or by my parents don't get me wrong I
think it's really important to get
advice there are a lot of different
sources and opinions from a lot of
different people that you respect and
admire however you need to realise that
especially if the people who are telling
you to go to universe are a lot older
they grew up in a different generation
when they were younger it was the dumb
thing to go to uni it was very cheap
there probably weren't as many other
avenues to go down as there are now so
that's just their own opinion I think
you need to shut yourself off maybe go
for a walk just make sure that you're on
your own and you're really thinking
about what you want for your life and
your potential future career because at
the end of the day do you think it's
important to find something you're
even if you're totally sure that
university is what you want to do you're
excited about going I still think it's
very interesting just to look at
possible other avenues because you never
know what could be out there there's a
lot of apprenticeships nowadays of ways
to learn on the job where you're getting
paid for it instead of having these
student loans and sometimes that can be
better as it gets you more experience it
won't get you the degree but it'll get
you other things so it's interesting to
see what other avenues might lead
towards your future goals and which one
might work best for you which also leads
on to my next question which is how do
you work best now this might seem like a
really strange question because we're
all grown up kind of working in the same
way in a classroom from textbooks
reading off whiteboards that some people
learn differently from that some people
are kinetic learners and they lands
through motion through experience and I
would say if you are one of those people
then perhaps doing something like an
apprenticeship where you're more
hands-on you're learning on the job
would be better for you however if you
really enjoy delving into a subject
matter that you absolutely love and a
passionate about for three whole years
writing essays on it researching the
history behind it that university is
definitely for you it's one thing that
they absolutely adore about uni now that
I can just kind of spend multiple hours
and evenings just absolutely going crazy
researching topics that I absolutely
adore
but I also understand that not everyone
works that way and that's perfectly fine
if you don't it doesn't make you any
better or any worse we're all different
were all unique we learn in different
ways and we need to embrace that as well
as apprenticeships are things like
online
horses if perhaps you want to work
alongside university or if you would
rather be in a more secluded environment
because they understand that the social
scene that comes with university even
though it's seen as being a primarily
positive thing it can be kind of
overwhelming for some people and again
that is perfectly okay in a sense of you
need to be a student and if the student
life I think that's a bit overrated and
you just need to stay true to who you
are and what you personally feel appeals
to you the most now after you've asked
yourself all of these questions I would
just simply say don't take this decision
too seriously and don't do me wrong here
because it is a serious decision it's
nine thousand pounds a year I mean it
might go up again hopefully not of
course yes this is important however you
don't need to do this right now I think
a lot of people put themselves under so
much pressure thinking that if they
don't go to university straight away
from school then they're missing out on
all this awesome stuff because their
friends are doing it and everyone's
telling them we should do it and it's
the dumb thing to do but know you can
take a year out you can take a couple of
years out and that's perfectly fine
honestly in my own experience I went and
did an apprenticeship I moved from my
home city to a bigger city in London
where I could experience
coding and things like that learn that
way and earn money so that I could
actually afford to live it was kind of
difficult but I wanted to live and I
would never have changed the decision
that I personally made because it worked
well for me it made me realize who I was
it got me out of my comfort zone got me
understanding a bit more about what I
love what my passions were and how I
worked as a human being and then I was
ready to dedicate myself to three years
of learning as
check that I knew would benefit me in
the future but it's daunting to go from
being a school student to studying in
university for those three years and
then leave without having that gap in
between to understand who you are or
even how the world works outside of the
education system I don't want to sway
you here I'm trying not to but I do
think life experiences a massive massive
assets for your own well-being as well
as your career whether you're deciding
to go to university or whether you're
thinking about going to university in
the future researching your universities
is vital like I've said it is a lot of
money to be spending it's three years of
your life that you can't get back and
you would hate to waste those in a
university that perhaps wasn't the right
one for you how do you even know what
university is right for you
I actually ended up going to uni
obviously after taking my couple of
years out and I actually feel like I
didn't do enough research if I'm honest
with you I kind of did it based off
location and the other types of students
that I thought I might meet but I didn't
really look into the course well enough
or what people said about the university
as a whole and it kind of regret that so
I don't want you to make the same
mistake as I did there are loads of
university fairs and also rankings
online that you can look into and of
course rankings shouldn't be how you
choose your University but it helps you
to figure out what universities are
globally seen as good ones and then you
can look into what courses they do
specifically the course that you want to
do and how that course stands in amongst
all their other courses here at top
universities they do top university
rankings so you can actually see which
universities are ranked up in the whole
world
or just UK
that you are so many countries and as
well as this they also provide qsr World
University tours where they go around to
countries all around the world and get
people together from universities and
students so they can talk get to know
each other and the students can get a
better idea of which university might
suit their really wish I knew about this
before I went to Union whatever very
helpful but now you know so you're
welcome
that was weird that was yeah that's
weird
never wink again so to sum this up
should you go to university I can't tell
you yes or no all I can do is share with
you my own experiences my own opinions
and let you know that these questions
asking myself really helped me whack out
where I was in my life and where I
figured I should be at that point
education is a very important time in
your life and I really feel like you
need to make the most of it especially
with University those three years can
offer you so much if you make sure that
you're going into it in the right
mindset if you're going into it for you
if you're going into it with a good
understanding of what you want to get
out of it those three years can be some
of the best in your life and can really
lay down the foundations for a happy and
fulfilling career because I took a
couple of years out and write in
advertising right in a london-based
company I understood what a career was
all about I understood how to act in the
professional world and it made me
realize what I wanted to do once I left
University and how I wanted to spend the
rest of my life so now while I'm in
university I can spend these three years
really grafting my youtube-channel
my expertise also form alliances with
company
and individuals outside of university
that I know can help me once I'm gone
because the university experience is
great in itself but I really do feel
like you need to kind of be planning for
after University because there's nothing
more scary than leaving the education
system without having a clue what's on
the outside and then just feeling a bit
lost but University can help you in so
many ways even if you feel like taking a
couple years out before University isn't
for you like it was for me we're all
different people they have internships
and they have connections with companies
outside of the Uni and I think you
should really use that it's the whole
point of being in uni you're paying a
lot of money and they have a lot of
services that can be used and as well as
this you're spending three years around
people who are hopefully like-minded and
just as passionate as you are about the
topic that you have chosen to research
why not use that to your advantage you
can even start your own business with
your own University friends and maybe
learn off each other just as much as you
learn off your lecturers that's part of
the fun of university exploring other
people's minds and just being constantly
curious about everything ask all the
questions university is where you get to
do that and no one looks down on you
it's great so anyway I am so happy that
I didn't go straight to uni my own
opinion I don't think it would have been
the same experience that I'm having now
however I do wish that I had researched
more about your needs before I went to
university but right now why I am in uni
I'm having fun there's at the end of the
day you only live once and your
happiness should be your main goal just
keep this hearing what makes you feel
most passionate whether university
sounds
to you or whether an apprenticeship
sounds appealing to you or whether
simply getting a full-time job saving up
and traveling the world appeals to you
go into it education is different for
everyone and life is different for
everyone we all aspire for different
things
and that's okay so just learn who you
are ask yourselves these questions just
do whatever feels right I'm sorry I
can't help you more than that but I
really hope my person experiences help
you you're a complete different person
to me so it's fine if we're completely
different in our points of view anyway
enough rambles if you want to hear more
about my life before University or my
time in university leave a comment below
as well as whether you want to go to
university went to go to university that
doesn't make sense I'd love to hear all
about your experiences whether you've
been in uni or not thank you very much
for top universities for having me today
I also did a video over on their channel
all about top ten essential things that
every student should take to university
so if you are going to uni then you
might want to check that video out the
link will be in the description below as
well as top university links of where
they do their World University tours and
things like that so you can get more
informed on the best universities in the
world and which one might be good for
you whether you're going to university
or not I wish you the very best in your
life and all the happiness and all that
jazz and have a lovely day or evening hi
well the record play little son oh my
god
I can't play guitar
I think it's out achene anyway
[Music]
boots and cats and boots and cats and
boots and cats and awful put it away put
it away we're now cool away one day I
will learn you guitar one day